let's say that you've got a blood vessel
here
and it's a longish blood vessel and
we'll give it a resistance of eight
and it has three branches
say two big ones and kind of a tiny one
in the middle
and this goes straight across
and this has a resistance of 10.
and these biggish ones
they
have resistance of let's say
half that
so they're about five
and
on this side they all come together
again
and enter a short vessel
this has a resistance of three
so my question to you is what is the
total resistance of blood
going in here
and out here so it's gonna have to go
through this eight
bit and then it has three choices here
here
here or here but eventually they all
come together again
into that three bit and then exit out
the other side so what is the total
resistance so what is rt for this that's
the question
and
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
divide into two parts part one
i'm going to figure out in part one what
the resistance is for this part right in
here
so
i can do that using an equation
i introduced in the last video which was
you can basically take r
t which is total resistance for that
yellow box
equals one over
one over five plus one over ten plus 1
over 5.
and i can
look at that and tell you the common
denominator is going to be 10 right
for all three
and here in the numerator i've got 2 1
and 2.
so putting it all together i've got 1
over what is that 5 over 10
and that equals
10 over 5
which equals 2.
so that tells me that the resistance in
this middle yellow box is 2.
and that makes sense with our rule
because we said that when things are in
parallel the total resistance is going
to be less than any component and in
fact 2 is less than 5 10 and 5 right
it's less than any of those numbers
individually
so we've got
now in part 2 we have
three things in series right we
basically have something like this we
have
8
and we have
two and we have
three
so we've got basically three things in a
series and so we simply add those up
so i'm gonna say rt now equals
8 plus 2 plus 3
and so rt equals 13.
so if i want to know what is my total rt
my total resistance
i would say
it is 13.
so
that's the answer to this problem and
what i want to get you thinking about is
total resistance for the body the human
body which has obviously more than you
know just a few vessels like i have in
this diagram you have
literally
thousands and thousands of vessels